okay whatever I think it's my chance
maybe
oh
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to security breach did
I scare you I don't know what happened
in the last episode I kind of just
blacked out but I hope everything is
fine
um we were chasing Roxy and
oh see what threw me off
what threw me off
is the fact that it started with like a
cut scene it took control of my camera
and in all the other times when there
has been intimate in Peril I wasn't able
to do anything so why would I think that
I would be able to do anything in this
one anyway that was my thought process
behind it you don't have to accept it
but it is what it is and that's just the
truth so
if you don't accept it that's on you
anyway require
who's doing this who who's doing this
who's doing this I have no idea
anywho wait a minute
my Spidey senses are tingling
nope never mind oh
what is that I guess I never really look
up
never really have a reason to but
whatever
well that's weird but nothing I need to
know about you think I would have seen
all these when I was going through the
game before but apparently not
damn it never mind I got it
okay
whoa my God
I don't have them
what
ever
error Roxy
are you a little confused because I
definitely am
huh
say something I can hear you can you
hear me yes I can
what happened here
it looks like the whole place fell in
something tunnel down broke everything
and now I'm stuck here oh yeah okay I
really think I need to go get help or
call the police what
how is that supposed to help there's no
time
fine am I even close
where are you this place is huge down
there sinkhole under the Raceway under
the Raceway
helpy how do I get down there
that area is on security lockdown great
also it's Roxy Raceway not Roxy Racers
do you want to save your friend you have
to shut down the remaining security
nodes in Bonnie bowl and phaser blast
phaser blast oh boy
[Music]
for me
[Applause]
well anyway that's super sad that that
occurs
but I've got places to be I've got
phasers to blast
seems like it
oh that doesn't look good
mudden look good at all well
okay
gross
extremely gross
and laggy
you loading something up there some
might need to worry about as soon as I
cross over this threshold
hello
hi
why is the light moving
oh that's why
yeah I know
okay what
wait a minute
that's not right
that's not right at all
wait a minute
something about this whole AR business
seems to be a perturbation on reality
it's range
okay whatever
fine then
keep your secrets
hello you gonna scare me what was that
no that's fine
why
this is fine hello
okay nothing special going on here
except the floor is undulating
what
I don't even know how that's happening
I don't even know why that's happening
okay don't mind me
yeah
knife safety watch where you're chopping
well that's a pizza cutter not exactly
an oh
well
at least she seems happy about it
but without that hand will be hard to
Vogue
hi
that's fine
nothing weird here
Oh see it was the wrong hand though the
other hand doesn't Boogie I got it
uh-huh interesting
that's glitchy
huh oh no there's a wall
I didn't just get scared by a wall
uh-huh
well that seems like I should go up in
there but I'm not 100 sure about that
nothing
weird
hey hey leave me alone
oh wait hold on wait but there's
not even anybody here they are Bonnie
mask oh that's the first mention of
Bonnie that I've seen what happened to
you
what happened to you I don't know what
happened to you you are approaching the
bowling area great hi what do you do
dude
do you do anything
are you currently doing anything
I know the general idea is that if there
was another animatronic here it would
come after me but by himself
he doesn't really do anything
oh
wait a minute what in the world
what where did they come from I mean
even in the other game I didn't know
where those guys came from so it's not
really a thing that they can answer but
it still seems odd where did they come
from all right but apparently oh God way
back here come here let me just grab the
neck
all right well that silence is
all right
thank you again very large shoes don't
know what that's about
I mean I guess it is just fake reality
over there
hello
peekaboo
oh
ah
okay
fascinating
incredibly fascinating
hello
I remember there being like something
important in the first game right about
here I just can't remember what it was
it has been a while
oh oh
ah that's why I died
that's why I died you a-holes
is Foxy going to come out
foxy
no oh wait a minute
wait a minute how you do that wait a
minute
how did I not notice you I don't know
I'm I'm
considerably dumb
and fantastically unobservant when it
comes to things
right in front of me
of course you're not real
why would you be hey wait a minute
okay
whoa
I see you there
something out here
hello
Chris Crossing what
oh
what is going on back there
what are you doing
what are you doing oh I see what you
doing Ah that's
not good
ah
yeah
yeah that's not good
um I don't know what to do about that I
don't know what happened to you and I
don't want to know so where's the things
and let me go
it's down here oh uh Roxy's big ball
whoa actually what the hell
weird I don't even know what's going on
down there why is it all polygonal
oh what
so are those gonna be Unleashed at some
point yeah those gonna be just Unleashed
am I gonna round the corner and be in
trouble
I have a feeling
oh
I'm fine that's fine come on over those
things
they look like the DJ they sure do
um they sure do I forget that you seem
to just like enjoy this place casually
which which is not okay all right so if
you're there I want you to go there
are you there are they just gonna go by
me wait
wait what
where is this
where is this where is this wait what oh
this isn't even on the map what
what is it what Gregory are you there
what is this what is going on here
what what does it have a symbol on it
what is that sorry I got distracted but
I don't know what
what
oh why what
okay whatever I think it's my chance
maybe
oh oh
well I
see I didn't see were you just like on
the ground or something because I didn't
see you all right so um
see how that wasn't exactly my fault
that was um
I'm just gonna go ahead and say it that
wasn't my fault
hey wait a minute
oh I was over here
what who is Whispering to me
what demon Gregory is Whispering to me
oh you are terrible what's wrong with
your face
oh all right whatever that's awful
um but not my problem Oh you probably if
I run into them it's bad news I don't
know what are you doing what are those
things
they look like the DJ I don't know
why I didn't know what I was doing I
guess they really do just come by if you
if you screw up like that whatever but
when I zoomed out I was at another
camera what was that about I've never
actually zoomed out on those cameras
before but when I was just going through
them there that wasn't anything what was
that has that always been like an option
where if you zoom out you can see other
cameras because I definitely couldn't
see that camera something about a
security checkpoint and I don't know why
that existed
so there was another camera system over
here if I zoom out on this one is it
gonna show two
no
I can't even zoom out on this one
okay but there's a whole mess of those
guys let me before I get into a new area
let me go ahead and get the other area
sorted before I can
feel good about myself and move on they
look like the DJ
what is that about
okay that opened what does that mean
what does that mean
seriously what does that mean I'm so
curious there's very few things in this
game that I thought were uh not linear
so if that actually changed something
like if I backtrack a bit to where I was
before was there a door down there that
I didn't see or didn't notice or thought
it was just closed and then I couldn't
do anything about it
because if that is the case and that's
fantastic and I I do like that
but what is that was there something
just bear with me for a minute I'm just
I'm doing some things I'm exploring I'm
I've never mind I'm not maybe never mind
I'm not oh
no
never mind I'm not exploring I'm not
doing anything I'm not trying something
new but I'm not gonna forget that that
did seem to open it wait where does the
think of writing that maybe the
curtain's going to open up and then
something's going to open up down there
and then I'm going to be able to
discover a secret all right but I got
something in front of me and I'm going
to solve it so I'm gonna skip ahead
until I get that okay all right
Gregory are you there
oh why that time
oh did I just get a lot Lucky in the
first time I did that I just got around
it whatever it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's fine okay so what I
think I have to do is I have to I have
to do the thing and then I gotta PJ get
out of there so that now I'm gonna do
this
intercoming on my I'm out of here don't
get me oh there they go ah yeah that
that that yeah that would probably yeah
okay
now it's free and clear and I think this
must be the thing oh yeah you're a big
bowling pin
all right good
good good good good good good good
okay wait why are they asleep
why are you sleep also why is that
glowing is there a way back there oh can
I get back there is that how I get down
there is that where it is oh don't kill
me don't do it what's wrong with your
face
creepy bastards
I'm glowing here
Lux
nah damn it
I thought it was I don't know what
that's about
it's kind of funky
it's kind of cool I like that all right
let's get this puzzle over with I've
been puzzling too long it's not even
really a puzzle this is a series of
tasks
wait a minute
what
wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa
whoa
what did you peer out of nowhere and you
just plop in like that is how I died the
first time I will be so much farther
you didn't do stuff like that
so don't do that
so you're going on patrol over there
cable is going that going that way looks
like it's going that way no but it's
coming from there and I Loop down there
and then back up here and they both go
over here
oh
something's freaking out
uh-huh
there we go get me out of here
what no no none of that really I don't
get that
I don't get the safety I don't get the
sanctity of something it's your fault
oh wait I can't kill you wait hold on
hold on wait a minute
oh you're gonna really get it now you
watch yourself
what am I looking for oh there they are
okay so if they're over there I'm
assuming that whatever I needed probably
over there so I need to wow
I need to lure them over there
Gregory are you there are you there oh
no that that wasn't ideal
is that actually oh it is helpful oh
yeah yeah yeah you stay there
oh man that you got it
oh no oh
oh
you're killing me me
I'm dying
Before I Forget before it gets me to an
area where I'm gonna go and I'm able to
come back
I'm gonna get this thing the floor sign
dude hi
you're sad very sad very soon
none of that none of that
none of that what do you think you're
doing oh god oh my god get away from me
I can't believe the first time I've had
an actual threat from an animatronic has
been from from these little guys
why are you here stop leave me alone I
need to do things oh God I can't I still
can't put on my mask
It's gotta be over here why is this one
such a pain in the ass
oh I can zoom out no nothing
all right I don't know what that is
I don't know where that is but I'm over
here I think I came in through there and
this is like some other way back around
I'm in the main entrance hallway or
something and I think the thing I gotta
go for is over there
but I'm right in the way
okay so since there's that there I
probably need to lure it that way but if
I leave that door locked I'm just gonna
get boned because it's gonna be hit
right in the middle of it so I better
open the door and then I have a path
around and then I can loop-de-loo and
everything will be fine yeah this is
like designed to take a while so
I'm very smart and good at games
therefore I recognize the fact that this
needs to be done way way way sooner
all right so if that's open then I have
a way to get all the way around right I
open that
so I've got a loop-de-loo so all I need
to do is drag it that way and then I can
run around and do all the things hey
don't worry I'm Gonna Get You
all right hey guys watch this
are you there you know I could just
shout out loud
I don't really need to do that are you
coming
oh they are okay that's good good to
know so all I need to do is go around
them and everything should be fine
because they will probably take long
enough
to be distracted sufficiently unless you
guys are back in your original spots
you might be
the frick they are if I can run around
them I'm very fast oh God oh God oh God
no God no God no don't don't do it don't
do it
okay weird ball
we got a weird ball we got AR inhibitor
oh big ball weird big ball
okay
we're good there then they're gonna come
back running around oh frick
when are they coming back and where are
they coming back are they coming
straight back
whoa hey wait run
now is the time to run
I disabled
the thing yeah that killed him I didn't
kill the other ones over there hi
all right thank you thank you goodbye
good night good night good night good
night
all right good
okay that's that was two but God two
still a pain in the ass who flung a
bowling ball into the screen
anyone see anything I guess in bathrooms
oh that's convenient okay whatever I
hello
how do you do
nothing oh
no this is my screen
what are you saying
oh hi
AR golden foxy
Hall guess he had to replace more than
his teeth
okay let's get another one of these so
this one goes over here and it's right
down in the middle of them
I don't even know where the thing is
there might be a computer
for the cameras somewhere around here
it was just one pipe running in there
and one pipe running wait
oh wait no duh there was another one in
here oh that's Oh I thought it was just
a path through I'm I'm real dumb guys
guys I don't know if you knew this but
um
afraid I
I'm very dumb
a very serious case of the I'm stupid
whatever
so
where do I go
what I'll do is I'll I'll just bring him
over here and then I'll loop around I'll
just go around you know what I'm talking
about you
listen to distractible
as you should
where are you oh wait whoa whoa what a
big cone really oh no I'm gonna get
sandwiched
oh I didn't know it was no no
not like that not between these losers
oh why do I gotta be killed by losers
why do they gotta be the most pathetic
ones possible why is that TV on I'm
going around I guess I'll go around oh
I didn't know it was big cone
where are you whoa you big cone
okay got it got it got it got it got it
got it got it got it okay I got it I'm
out of here are you you're all dead
right you're dead now you died
you died
you died let me just confirm that I got
the floor thing I'm pretty sure they
died oh good they're dead no one's dead
great
I've deactivated all the children so
there's got to be something over here
that is another terminal that can allow
me to get to where I need to be unless
this is just a matter of going Ring
Around the Rosie and leading them
personally because that could be how it
is they're not oh never mind
okie dokie
uh you're looking at those guys you're
looking over there so oh you were trying
to get me well it's not gonna work
Gregory
are you there
are you there are you there oh
okay yeah you stay away
oh wait wait a minute what
what what no don't oh I ran out of
go okay you're I hate you why would they
just do that why would they do that that
doesn't make any sense why would they
just do that that's not cool
stop
what stop
don't do that why are you still doing
this I told you to stop that's when you
stop
you stop when I say stop
and then you don't do it oh and they're
still over there they didn't even go
hello hey stop I don't like you guys I
don't know if I made that clear enough
that's what I thought yeah you're afraid
aren't you
hey a little scared huh
I don't understand
is it mic activated are they listening
in
huh
this is
I don't get it how about this Gregory
are you there
I'm gonna wait till I see them all leave
are all going
and then they're all assembling right
there I see them all they're right there
and I'm gonna draw them over here now
are you there and then I look here and I
don't see any of them
so I think we're in business
okay big shoe big shoe
bam I did it I did it I did it I'm out
of here
I did it
okay so I get to see maybe maybe if
we're lucky what's behind Foxy's
curtains was it a thing where like when
Rock whoa when Roxy appeared in this one
it was like there was something about
how they kind of just repurposed and
reprogrammed the base animatronic and
then put a different
exterior on it and that's how they did
changes like that or something I don't
remember I I feel like that was a thing
right
but maybe I'm
uh
uh how in the frick are you what
wait
them that has to go there so you have to
go this way
do not you you just let me throw a
puzzle
let me do a puzzle you can't even do
anything on your own there's a weird
cyber rabbit I got that I got it I got
it hold on for babies it's for babies
for babies because this goes up and then
over and then that goes uh right there
for babies for babies
it's for babies okay oh
well uh well I guess it was all an AR so
yeah all right but hey oh
that's weird because I I did just have
that on
huh
all right
but I think this must be where
that other door was right
hi
what you doing there
oh my God
did you manually
was this your job did you manually
reload the bowling boots
are you moving
no
that'd be crazy if you were moving
you and me forever and ever love Freddy
I'm sure
I'm really sure well Bonnie oh good job
that vent connects directly to phaser
blast
every single time I get in one it breaks
or something jumps out at me
this is the shortest safest path to
phaser blast if you prefer you may
elevator
I I don't know I kind of prefer the
the Elevator Shaft
interesting where was that door
it felt like the door was somewhere
behind
hi
were you always there
oh my God you were I just want to
confirm where this security door might
have been I just want to double check
before because I've done this before
with like oh I missed an area or
whatever but there was something here ah
it's just like my Spidey senses are
tingling me unless you see me pause this
video
hi it's me this is a little too on the
nose for my taste but if it's not clear
I'm speaking broadly about things that I
don't fully understand with the
confidence that I usually attribute to
how I normally make videos
this confidence is misplaced and I'm
just going to skip ahead to where I
actually get back on track but
just know I'm still gonna Ramble On as
if I know what I'm talking about
which I don't
okay I'm gonna go
I'm definitely not missing anything I'm
definitely not I'm missing something
wow
what was that
hi
this uh I'm not uh
this is some vent
that was a phaser blast phaser blaster
with them
oh a sword
a sword I got a sword oh I'm gonna sword
it all
oh who's sleeping here oh wait it's
vany's room
oh oh and that's what the sword is is
from that arcade game right
okay well I was right about never being
able to come back so for this being what
it is there sure is a whole lot of
nothing here but wasn't there a window
looking into this area before
not just a door wasn't there a full-on
window and
all right whatever
can't do any of it anyway I can't grab
this
so I guess I go down here
what
weird
oh I see what it is I just I didn't
notice what it was in it all right
okay I'm going in the vent again
not like I didn't just go an event oh
wait no there was event that went around
in the Vanity's place but it there must
be two different places because
I remember from that cutscene that was a
comic book
I remember
oh is that where I fell I don't know
don't make any sense
so did I miss out on that door thing
security notes are all the way down
there
sperm
oh
weird
ah the memories
good memories
so us with a big old glowing
mobus ball
I don't know
what oh bad bear bad bad bear
fast fiend fast fiend
no Freddy
Fazbear bad the birth
I think they're trying to tell me
something I think Freddy might be here
and he maybe not be very good
I think it might be a bad bear which
would be sad but I
he doesn't see you
which would be interesting because
that's what I thought they were going
for in the first game that the more
upgrades you gave them the better he
would be
so where am I going and how have I
missed out on so many things already
tell me tell me my woes
interesting
I don't know about that one
I thought that was a crowbar
okey dokey so I probably need to find
myself a fast blaster
oh yeah oh yeah let's jump in a weird
portal okay
I'm not scared
my friend
regularly where are you going
okay I'm gonna level with you guys you
know how those things on the ground you
know sometimes uh they make sounds and
stuff and you know they have voice lines
right
so
I'll add it in a spooky thing like that
ah well this is a problem
um okay uh well I can't even take this
off at the moment
um
okay
ah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I'm about to die am I about am I
about to die am I am I about to die
anyway I started adding those in
to the things on the floor without
knowing that this was actually a thing
I'm dead serious I did not know
okay didn't freaking know
it's literally using that's not me
that's not me doing that
okay
if that wasn't clear
I didn't know
Lucian did you know didn't think so we
didn't know
that's weird
anyway I'm gonna go deactivate the nodes
now
I think there's a bad bear here guys
there might be a bad bear
okay just gonna go in what is that what
why but I just did it I literally just
dude it
ah
okay I'm just gonna go in I'm gonna go
in the hole thank you all right I did it
hey get out of here you
all right
so yeah anyway
um didn't know about any of that and
whatever that well my point from before
was whatever that was that's what I mean
prototype
Freddy Freddy are you okay
wait a minute it's a bad bear guys it's
a bad bear
oh my God I'm out of Sprint well might
as well look at my whoa okay all right
you know what that that I don't like
that I'm gonna go ahead and say that I I
don't like that I don't like that much
at all
oh my goodness
okay anybody got a phaser blaster
anyone
oh
that is right though
in wait no wait wait
oh
what
Freddy
huh
Freddy oh
my God okay Freddy uh wow
I really hope you aren't currently where
I'm supposed to go because that would be
incredibly inconvenient for me
um but yeah in the end didn't didn't
Freddy's head get taken with Gregory
I believe
oh where are you I was just I didn't
know how disconcerting a headless Freddy
was going to be because man I don't like
him especially with his like pink chest
ugh don't play peekaboo with me peekaboo
you can't get me anyway why do you have
spikes I don't like anything about you
yeah this is a prototype anyway that's
not the real Freddy right
it's got a name written on his bootleg
like a woody
all right
well nothing to do for me okay I'll go
for it I guess
oh wait no hold on huh
foreign
it has like no presence in AR
oh
that has some implications
that has some deep concerning
implications
well I Gotta Die once oh God
that was a goodie probably a fast
Blaster if I had to guess but even if I
got it it would be of no use because
Freddie doesn't have eyes
so I couldn't shoot him in the eyes
it's a perfect defense so um oh good
thank you and allowed me to get that
underway but okay bye also why was Roxy
suddenly like oh I'm sorry
that was that was even weirder than this
and this is weird this is really weird
you can't crawl in here right I'm gonna
end this here because I may have
wandered around a bit but I'm all out of
time for this episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm Gonna
Leave You in the capable arms of Mr Fred
the E Playa
have fun with him thank you and as
always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]